economía en france 24 me acompaña en el
estudio daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches comenzamos hablando de
américa latina- cuba está impulsando una
nueva reforma para abrir el espacio a
las empresas privadas algo que hace unos
años era impensable allí claro de
santiago hoy en día hay una lista de 127
actividades que pueden ejercer las
empresas privadas ese listado se
ampliaría a más de 2000 según
declaraciones de la ministra de trabajo
martha elena feito recogidas por los
medios locales en su lugar habrá una
lista de 124 actividades que no se
pueden ejercer por el sector privado no
ha sido revelada de manera oficial pero
se habla de que entre éstas podrían
permanecer campos como la salud
educación telecomunicaciones energía o
prensa esta es una reforma de la que se
ha hablado por mucho tiempo santiago
pero que cobra importancia justo ahora
en plena pandemia ampliar el papel de
las pequeñas empresas pueden
efectivamente ayudar a reactivar la
golpeada economía y crear empleos más de
600 mil personas hoy trabajan en el
sector privado pero esto es apenas un
13%
la fuerza laboral activa la mayoría de
ellos trabaja en la industria del
turismo
daniela hablemos ahora de eeuu porque ya
están pensando en ponerle un tope a esos
alivios económicos que está dando el
gobierno por la crisis económica por la
pandemia pero específicamente para los
que ganen más claro hoy hay mucha
expectativa por el paquete de estímulos
de 19 billones de dólares propuesto por
el presidente joe valdez pero todavía no
ha sido votado en el congreso que ahora
como sabemos está muy pendiente del
proceso de impeachment contra donald
trump además los republicanos ven este
plan de rescate muy grande y puede que
no lo aprueben hoy se conoció que el
mandatario buscará limitar el alivio a
quienes tengan ingresos menores a 250
mil dólares por año y así se los debió
explicar a los directores ejecutivos de
grandes empresas como jaypee morgan
chase walmart y gap con quienes él se
reunió este martes para explicarles ese
paquete pasamos ahora a huahuel que
demandó precisamente a eeuu para que le
permita vender sus equipos allí en la
unión americana bueno primero hay que
decir que el año pasado la comisión
federal de comunicaciones
y designó formalmente a la china huawei
como una amenaza a la seguridad nacional
con esto le impide vender miles de
millones de equipos en este país
incluidos los de la tecnología 5g la
acción legal presentada en un tribunal
de apelaciones de nueva orleans este
martes solicita que se retire justamente
esa declaratoria y dice que el gobierno
de eeuu no aportó pruebas sustanciales
para imponer ese castigo precisamente
una vez
joe biden tomó posesión huawei dijo de
inmediato que espera que las relaciones
con la casa blanca mejoren
sustancialmente hablamos ahora de la
escasez de chips que está poniendo freno
de mano a la industria automotriz a
nivel mundial se trata de santiago de
microprocesadores para la fabricación de
autos que provienen de países como
taiwán y cuya oferta actual es
insuficiente para todos porque al
parecer se está dando prioridad para la
fabricación de otros equipos como
celulares tablets o relojes inteligentes
inclusive entre otros
algunos fabricantes de todo el mundo
como honda nissan volkswagen y general
motors están teniendo problemas para
ensamblar vehículos sin esta pieza este
martes la general motors anunció que
extenderá la suspensión de la producción
de automóviles en tres de sus plantas
ubicadas en eeuu en méxico y en canadá
hasta mediados de marzo por cuenta de
este inconveniente y en enero
fort se vio obligado también a eliminar
turnos de trabajo e incluso suspender la
producción debido a estos problemas de
suministro de chips pasamos ahora los
indicadores como el smart las
principales bolsas alrededor del mundo
santiago wall street cerró mixto pero
hubo un tercer récord consecutivo para
el índice tecnológico nasdaq la mayoría
de las bolsas europeas por su parte de
cerró a la baja los analistas dicen que
los inversionistas están recogiendo los
beneficios de las buenas jornadas
anteriores y en américa latina' también
hubo resultados dispares con buenas
ganancias para la bolsa de méxico
cifra del día pareciera usted que es tan
activo en twitter le va a interesar esa
cifra santiago cuéntame en los 1.135
millones de dólares que generó twitter
en pérdidas durante 2020 a pesar de que
tuvo más ingresos y que alcanzó los 192
millones de usuarios activos también
dijo haber tenido pérdidas relacionadas
con la pandemia y altas provisiones para
el pago de impuestos impensable en medio
de la pandemia cuando todo podría
haberse transmitido a través de twitter
muchas gracias daniel as todo en la
economía siga con nosotros
[Música]